[Music]
well it's time to share some home-cooked
pasta but someone I don't get to see
enough these days I'm talking about my
friend Andy Richter hey Andy hey Conan
thanks for having me over
what are we sharing today I'm glad you
asked a nice big plate of penne Rigate
doesn't that look great it sure does
reads ad copy man that prego pasta sauce
is thick no wonder it's the number-one
pasta sauce in America done with your
commercial yet Andy just about done now
why don't I give you a nice big bite of
pasta only if I can give you a big bite
of pasta too are you ready
you bet I am really good you know what a
fork pool is so small I think we can get
more if we just use our hands okay
there's good pasta I don't even care
about the pasta any wires what the flop
isn't this great Andy oh it's always
great to share pasta with a friend
thanks going in Borrego yeah I know it's
prego we've been talking about it the
whole time no Andy prego means you're
welcome
don't you [ __ ] me if you've got some
kind of code you're speaking in you
better trigger it means you're welcome